Mike's in Arizona hi Mike welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show thank you Dave how are
you doing today better than I deserve
what's up a quick question for you here
we been on your plan for several years
now in our depth three just took our
30-year loan into a 15-year loan and
plan on having that paid off in ten so
it's time to ramp up and get serious
about investing we've been talking to a
couple different LPS for financial
planning and a question my wife asked
last night was should political
affiliation with who we're going to
invest in come into play when making a
decision hmm it's an interesting
question well you mean smart Wester pros
or who you're speaking with right yes
okay
the primary thing I'm looking for is can
I trust their advice and can I learn
from them so that I can make my own
decisions with their advice and so I
think it might be depending on how
strongly you feel about political
affiliation if you are a staunch
fill-in-the-blank working with someone
that is staunch opposite means they have
a different value system than you
probably it's not just a different it's
not just a different way of looking at
life I mean there it is a different way
of looking life it's a different value
system and so that would it might
concern me if I were you know like I'm
not like on silent well I would get into
it but it doesn't matter the I'm
generally gonna land on the right on
most things and on some things way right
for instance economic issues I'm
libertarian more than anything else I
just leave me alone
that's me okay on economic issues and so
some guy who is a big Bernie supporter
might be a concern to me if it was me
doing it or vice versa if you're
if you're a big bernie guy and the guy
you're working with like just to the
right of Genghis Khan you know you may
you may want to rethink that right yeah
that's that's fair right that's fair
because they're handling your money now
you're not turning the caveat the thing
that makes it okay if you don't want to
lean into that too hard is that you're
not really turning it over them to make
the decision right but they're back
their worldview does affect the advice
that they give you so is that a question
do you think I should bring up and I
mean would they be offended by that or
is that something that I should ask in
the questions when interviewing if it's
concerning to you I would ask it and if
they're offended by Tuffy's okay your
money yep it's your money you need that
you're the one needs to get comfortable
here not them right so you know if they
don't like that if again if you're if
it's a big deal to you and like I've got
a friend who just is raving about this
stuff right so it would never want to he
would definitely that'd be something
he'd want to talk about then I got other
people who are just like turned the
stupid TV off I got work to do you know
and they're not worried about it at all
they're kind of you know they have a
they have an opinion but they don't
spend half their life talking about
whether it's Trump or Obama they've
actually got work to do you know and
they're not there's not worried about it
and so if you're in that camp then you
don't maybe you don't worry about it
right and and so I'm okay but yeah the
political thing is not because you can't
trust someone of a different political
opinion it's because their worldview is
going to all of our worldview effects
are the advice that we give affect our
beliefs affect our advice of it beliefs
are affect our decisions now again
you're not going to invest money unless
you understand what it's going into and
why but you know an example would be if
you really hate Trump and you think that
you think the Democrats actually have a
case and you think he's going to get
impeached and you think that means the
stock market's going to crash then
that's the way affects your of advice
you'd be screaming like chicken little
like get out of the market get out of
the market get out of the market it's
getting ready to go bad but if on the
other hand you think
this is one big collective yawn and you
know it's just a sideshow
a political sideshow that actually is
not ever going to amount to anything
which is what actually most people
believe right now but if that's the case
then you're not really worried about the
stock market which is continued to shoot
up so your beliefs do affect your
decisions and they affect your your
worldview affects your advice that's
I've never had anybody ask that but
that's an interesting thing to think
about so you know the more concern you
are about it the more I would be tempted
to ask about it I have never asked about
it because I'm not really that concerned
about how I'm gonna make my decisions
independent of these groups anyway
they're giving me advice they're gonna
teach me I'm gonna learn but if they say
something crazy like you know the
markets getting ready to crash I'm just
like yeah probably need different guy
because I just don't think it's gonna
crash you know I'm okay and so you know
that that's you know you just you just
decide that right but I got a friend
that's a conspiracy theorist from now on
he believes every conspiracy theory
there is everything about the world's
coming to an end
the world's coming in and the world's
coming to the world's coming to an end
and of course he's not investing anyway
so but see it affects your affects your
that's interesting it does affect your
investment decisions never really
thought about though